welcome to sturgeon Creek farm this is a
family operation that we've done
Wilson's sturgeon Creek farm in Jackson
County has been in his family since 1831
before Jackson County was a county today
Wilson the eldest of three sons farms
these rolling hills with his three sons
formerly a diversified farm with cattle
hogs and tobacco Wilson now runs a
cow-calf operation with both commercial
and registered Angus cows he calls it a
typical Mountain farm without the bells
and whistles
Wilson is working with Jackson County AG
Extension agent David Coffey improving
her genetics in his breeding program but
it's about more than just that it's it's
the total operation it's it's how we're
managing forage is how we're going to
manage water how we're doing a nutrient
that was produced on the on the farm
through the manure how we manage that
how we manage our wildlife have a
manager our timber just a total program
Wilson has big goals for his farm for
improving forages fencing and rotational
grazing and letting the cattle do most
of the grazing while cutting some for
hay those ideas are in line with what
coffee has in mind and with this program
I wanted to focus on the broad entire
operation so everything from their
forages their genetics their you know
rotational grazing their even their
forestry and you know horticulture if
somebody's doing some of that so I
wanted to check to try to you know cover
everything and just help them to better
manage exactly what that producers doing
Wilson is one of about 17 producers who
started out in the program two years ago
including the happy Hollow Farm owner
Bob Hornsby is working to downsize his
cow numbers from 125 to about 50 to make
it more manageable he is adopting many
of the principles on his farm being
touted by coffee
to get on a total pastor program maybe
feed one month the other year or just
when it snows so I worked with David
quite a bit on that he did all soil test
last year and so we've got our soil
testing so we work very hard this year
to try to get everything hopefully we
don't have a drought
Hornsby plans to use rotational grazing
using nine pastures to move his cows
through to utilize the forages and
hopefully feeding less hay Hornsby and
Wilson are trying to follow the plan
designed by coffee and so far it seems
to be working I've been very pleased
with with the progress and the results
from it and what a lot of these guys are
doing they've made some real progress
and to look at it you might not think
it's that much difference but it was
just like we said here at me on 500
acres you make one one change in
management you know that influences the
whole operation a lot from the
University of Kentucky College of
Agriculture Food and environmental